hey guys I'm Greg can I'm John
housewarming party just finish I'll
drink 45 in the morning baby driver
trailer number 1 I'm excited about this
I just found out recently that this was
the thing and I just found out moments
to go a little bit more about that thing
and now I'm excited to tell to see it
John the biggest tiger I found my goai
so much is big a ziggurat ban on now all
matter oh my oh no design your day or
did you just it off
hey call I got you oh it's this guy what
is it you do
[Music]
Oh leftover God yeah anyone
[Music]
humberto baby your name baby baby my
baby you're right style Kevin he's gone
maybe a mental mental meanie flow with
his flow
no he had an accident when he was a kid
still has a hum in the drum plays music
to drown it out and that's what mixing
with it one more job and we're straight
I don't think I need to give you the
fuel I haven't anything know how I could
break your legs to kill everyone you
love because you already know that gun
yeah once you get to remove your
kissable and your waitress girl nicely
to keep it that way
one drive is why standing strong like a
baby
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow yes I'll have it all [ __ ]
fantastic it's a good time to be an
action fantasy actually slower budget
action thrillers hell yeah dude I mean
there's definitely humor in it but I
wouldn't call it like another egg or
write comedy this is not your son you
know seven peg Nick's rustle humor no
but there's good rhythm yeah yeah yeah
what a cast man what's that guy's name
Ansel Elgort Ansel Elgort holy [ __ ]
you're getting you're gonna become an
action hero but any kind of sexy is
gonna become an action hero we're gonna
Fred I like Jon Bernthal and Jon Hamm
bulb and do badass characters wielding
guns Jamie Foxx but I'm excited age
mainly because of Jon Hamm out of all
the I'm Bernthal Jamie Foxx have seen
them do that before that's why I like it
but ready but Jon Hamm oh I know it is a
good a super excited just to see what
they're going to do with anger right cuz
I Guerette got so much personality would
like to see Jon Hamm and I feel like
this yeah I'm on in what looks like is
going to be at least you know uh
something of an imposing role like I'm
not at all like I mean I was reminding
me of drive and the in terms of its plot
driver baby driver and then he falls in
love with a woman who's a waitress and
you know it wants to escape of her
because her life is you know it's
writing but this one he's like - maybe I
feel like I might share a little too
much in a trailer or think about it
maybe I'm not trying to remember all
those details yeah yeah he's like trying
to escape town with her and leave with
her to keep her safety and plus you need
to get away driver so got some cool [ __ ]
and makes him the best right animal time
y'all - you think you belay just kidding
yeah it kind of unlikely but always a
job and I like the touch of cuz and
blade Trinity there was a close movement
there's a cool touch - Jessica Biel's
character that came across a little
cheesy it looks like it's really cool
here I just gonna be able to listen to
her music when she fights
okay and here it makes sense that you
would you know like how he could drive
better yeah song you know and knowing
egg arrest that you like some like Scott
Pilgrim vs. the world as well yes yeah
so I got her over summary I got pilgrim
you know music is such an implemental
parts of the way that film was directed
and edited all the way the scenes are
structured because a lot of that is
about music in this character he's about
music - and I feel like Drive was a lot
about its music as well
oh definitely well and then you know
Edgar Wright movies all of them have
unique music cues and a heavily curated
soundtrack but I I get why he interned
you know get along and I feel like they
have a similar thing all director right
I always get a little bit there's a lot
of references that were at work and a
lot of interesting music cues but I feel
like you know in a markedly different
land maybe a little less well I think
it's because their love for film started
interrupt this happens what I've been
drinking all night and it's haunted I
remember I feel like Edgar Wright and
Tarantino are very much they love to
work with in genre yes and they had
their love for film and homage the film
really takes place and a lot of their
work and material I can see why they're
why the way they would like respect each
other yeah so cuz you know thinking
about Edgar Wright's you know we think
of more like a Cornetto trilogy when you
think of any beggar rights movies and
you know while there were comedies
they also honored that genre that will
be a part of its role as well because I
was what I think you think about like
Shawn a bit
like those are hilarious but they're
also kind of badass yeah yeah it proves
it like oh they know these the genre
inside yeah they're not just commenting
on like they're recreating and I know
that John Rowe like they're love letters
too you know and it feels like with this
movie instead of having to really do a
comedy he he's just showing I could do a
badass action jewelry you know this
Edgar Wright second you have a lot of
editing month you can see a lot of that
in the trailer look like yeah yeah his
style is cool anywhere it goes and I'm
really interested now to see what it
looks like when he's on his own you know
when not yeah you know cuz because this
is this an original concept yeah yeah
wrote at a record this yeah yeah I'm
fascinated by that because you know when
I when he gets together with Simon Pegg
and Nick Frost you know I get there's a
certain ID I have of what that's going
to look like and then when he just got
pilgrim you know you've got the source
material but now he's bright down to his
own sing and I'm really excited to see
where this part of the career totally
he's creating a criminal underworld and
I hope was good like I'm really excited
like it's been a while since we've heard
from him so I'm I couldn't be more
excited I mean yeah last time we all
expected to room with ant-man
ya know he's coming out baby driver now
oh man anyone to do his like he is you
know was just doing what you might think
I'm sure do my see you know baby driver
a be there people with any time I go
rights around on there see whenever
would you like a top down with like most
anticipated in 2017 so they released
like the huge trailers in 2016 yeah but
if I saw they're like the baby driver
trailer and at the atomic blonde trailer
helling lighting 2016 at some point I
would be like those movies are for sure
on my list yeah this looks sweet all
right guys you can subscribe to the real
vinayak John Green so Jerry have Twitter
and Instagram social media manager Blum
houses the real rejects and shout out to
Nick Frost the targeted movie fights but
he could be the next jean-claude Van
Damme